later this season on below deck down
under
[Music]
[Applause]
that's insane get the croc out of here
[Applause]
they're going a little stir crazy
what is happening
one two three oh they're totally making
babies call that what do you like in a
girl a chemistry that almost feels like
a drug black ferrari
bursini and culver just need to smooch
thanks
i want to climb up the ladder then they
have to climb up with me
a laugh fake laugh just vague you're two
faces
two-faced i just really pride myself on
how hard i work this was for the
philosophers hold up you were drinking
more than one don't start with me my
friend jamie knows who he thinks he is
but he doesn't tell the captain to wait
let me finish my dinner and you can talk
about it no no no no no listen i don't
want your attitude no i'm your captain
if you want to bring it up three
decibels i'll bring it up for
with that
i had to make a decision i'm going to
let you go
oh i like this all
right
call me a loser dude
i dragged me the rest of the way
[Music]
you